the word equality is evil and I'm
starting to think this I might be going
too far with this but what are human
rights like there's gonna be rules in
every society you're in you know what I
mean like I was literally thinking I'm
like what is a human right because you
don't have the right to do everything
like I don't have the right to kill
someone I don't have the right to steal
but the government has the right to
steal from me you know what I mean
but but it's like because the idea is
like in history or be a king they would
make up some rules and you'd live under
those rules and if you didn't like it it
could be exiled I don't know I haven't
finished that thought but I was I was
thinking about equality is evil because
no one's evil and then I was thinking
about how a lot of people guys like woke
organizations under the idea of Human
Rights but what rights do people have
like nobody has the right to do anything
so